l'afghanistan toujours en proie aux
offensives des talibans les insurgés
djihadistes contrôle de cuisinière leur
toute première capitale provinciale les
arrange située à la frontière avec
l'iran une ville d'importance économique
qui permet aux rebelles islamistes de
renforcer leur emprise sur les zones
frontalières de quoi inquiéter le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qui s'est
réuni hier à new york
il
s'agit de violations du droit
international des droits de l'homme du
droit international humanitaire et
certaines d'entre elles constitueront
des crimes de guerre nous attendons donc
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
s'ils interviennent et prenne des
mesures immédiates
les talibans ne sont pas intéressés par
la paix la paix exigera un temps où les
armes se taisent
la paix exigerait des mesures de
confiance
vous ne pouvez pas terroriser la
population d'une part déclencher une
attaque massive contre des villes puis
aller à doha et parler de paix d'autre
part
l'afghanistan se trouve maintenant un
tournant dangereux l'avenir est soit à
une véritable négociation de paix soit à
une série de crises tragiquement un
briquet
un conflit de plus en plus brutale
combinée à une situation humanitaire
aiguë
et à une multiplication des violations
des droits humains si
c'est maintenant un autre type de guerre
qui rappelle la syrie récemment ou
sarajevo dans un passé pas si lointain
la menace de grandes zones urbaines
apparaît comme une décision stratégique
des talibans qui ont accepté le carnage
probable qui s'ensuivra